Welcome back everyone this is good to be my
new House the Dragon trailer video all for
daemon targaryen Matt Smith character because
he's such a huge character on the show in
such an important figure in the new old battle
for the iron throne.
Even though the new battle technically this
is taking place in the past.
So it's an old battle for the iron throne
is a bunch of cool references in Easter eggs
in the trailer that tie him to the characters
from the main show in present day.
Like Jon Snow and Daenerys.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand-new to the channel, of course
will be doing episode videos for this when
they start releasing so be sure to subscribe
to get all those to be a lot like the videos
I did for the main show game of thrones.
But the House the Dragon trailer is narrated
by Matt Smith daemon targaryen like he talks
about fire and blood.
The motto the targaryen family how the secret
of their power is all about dragons and even
though they don't show you a lot of dragons
are in the trailer I believe the be at least
17 different dragons on House the Dragon because
this is all about the targaryen civil war
and during this era in history pretty much
all the main players the major members the
Royal family all have their own dragons.
None none of them are as big as did nurses
dragons.
But some of them are really big.
But within the context of the series within
a song of ice and fire during this period
in history daemon targaryen has a bunch of
different names the people call him by some
of them nicer than others.
He's called the Prince of the city the Prince
of the king's landing city that is the Lord
of flea bottom in the road Prince the last
name is probably the most important one, especially
for this video because it foreshadows his
epic long game of thrones that he plays to
win the iron throne for himself amidst all
these different factions vying for so even
though the main part of House the Dragon is
all about the dance the dragons the main targaryen
civil war when they say in the trailer the
show picks up 200 years ago in the past that
she starts way before the actual conflict
the war itself.
The dance the dragons that only lasted for
a couple years, so there's a lot of stuff
leading up to the dance the dragons of the
going to show us in the series in the episodes,
especially in the early seasons.
Probably the teaser trailer shows us most
of the important factions the dance the dragons
had to main factions the Blacks and the greens
led by Rhaenyra targaryen this character here,
there's a young version of her character in
the past in the earlier part of the timeline and later
there's an older version of her character
here with daemon targaryen and the greens
are led by Alicent Hightower.
This is the older version of her character
they've also cast a younger version of her
character too when they do episode set in
the past or when they do flashbacks to the
past HBO hasn't officially clarified how the
going to handle that if they'll just be flashbacks
to the past that shows how things got to present
day or the be like full blown episode set
in the past.
Yes that is the catspaw's dagger arias valyrian
dagger that she used to kill the night king
that she's holding during this much earlier
in the timeline is not really important for
the purposes of this video I talked a lot
more about it during my previous trailer video
all link that at the end of this and down
the description below.
But even though you see the dance the dragons
having to main factions there actually a lot
of different players involved all.
Who themselves are vying for the iron throne
is a battle of succession kind of like the
HBO series succession where you have all these
different family members vying to take over
for their father.
But the fact that Matt Smith daemon targaryen
is narrating the trailer just tells you how
important he is to the series and how bigger
character he's going to be he's very much
a schemer in a plotter in the way that Jon
Snow or Aegon targaryen everyone to think
about him never was like Jon Snow said I don't
want it when it was found out that he had
a strong claim to the iron throne daemon targaryen
story during House the Dragon, his quest for
the iron throne all the twists and turns along
the way bear a lot of similarities to Jon
Snow and Daenerys a story.
So remember after it was discovered the Jon
Snow also had a claim to the iron throne and
they started their relationship formally him
and Daenerys.
All hail the sex boat things got really complicated
between them.
It's the same situation with daemon targaryen
and a lot of the other main characters.
Remember, these of the targaryen so sister
wiping was very common amongst them when I
said the show picks up about 200 years before
present day, which is the events of the main show
That means is going to pick up around the
events where his brother Viserys the first
took the iron throne.
So Viserys the first is the current reigning
king during House the Dragon you see him sitting
on the iron throne their he's holding Blackfyre
the valyrian sword the belong to Aegon the
conqueror the sword of kings.
So though start somewhere between the early
part of his reign in the middle part, because
there were just so many things that happened
during his reign that help explain how the
dance the dragons targaryen civil war got
started while the really important players
do what they did particularly why daemon targaryen
is doing what he's doing on the show because
his brother Viserys the first became king
after a similar squabble within the targaryen
family over who the next king should be when
his and Daemon's grandfather Jaeherys the
first the previous king died without a male
heir what happened was is a Jaeherys the first
had many sons but they all died through various
means before he died some of them did have
their own families with grandchildren.
So here's we get to the whole comparison to
Jon Snow and Daenerys a storyline as was the
case in present day with Jon Snow and Daenerys
as was the case back then during this era
in history, the line of succession typically
skipped over women so if a king died without
a male heir, the line of succession would
pass to his closest living male relative if
he had a brother or if he had grandsons, it
would past of them.
So when Viserys the first became king there
was a full-blown civil war.
Like the dance the dragons.
But there was a big argument amongst the Lords
of the kingdom over who the next king should
be this woman here is actually important she's
Rhaenys targaryen she's the wife of Corlys
Velaryon obviously this is a much older version
of her character.
She was technically the next person in line
for the iron throne after Jaeherys died, so
she should have had a stronger claim to the
throne of them Viserys the first because her
father was the older brother of Viserys and
Daemon's father, but because she was a woman
during the great council that was called to
determine who had the strongest claim the
other Lords of the Council were persuaded
the pastor over in favor of the closest living
male heir, which was Viserys the first that's
why Rhaenys here is also called the queen
who never was now she was a badass within
her own right obviously this is a much older
version of her character who has her own family
with Corlys Velaryon while this was all playing
out in the great council daemon targaryen
also played a big part in rallying support
for his brother's claim to the iron throne
and this is where we get to his whole long
game for the iron throne's all the scheming
and plotting and palace intrigue that everybody
love so much about the early seasons of the
main show.
The reason why Daemon was such a supporter
of his brother's claim to the iron throne
was because he loved him so much and he was
the best brother in the world was because
at the time Daemon thought of himself as his
brother Viserys is heir, because at that time
they were both adults.
But Viserys had not gotten married yet and
had no children.
So Daemon technically would've been next in
line for the iron throne when Viserys was
crowned king Daemon was given the title Prince
of Dragonstone.
That's also why you see so much footage of
him at dragonstone in the trailer that in
is just a really important location for the
targaryen family just in general.
So within the House the Dragon series.
Even though this is all about the dance the
dragons civil war between Rhaenyra targaryen
and Alicent Hightower really daemon targaryen
has been playing the long game for the iron
throne since before both of them were born
and you kind of see this play out in the trailer
with the two different timelines, but in the
trailer when you see the footage of Rhaenyra
walking into the throne room approaching the
new but old version of the iron throne the
more book accurate iron throne with the melted
down swords all around it.
The transition between the younger version
of her character in the older version.
What is the older version here.
The person sitting on the iron throne that
she's looking at it as she approaches is actually
Matt Smith daemon targaryen as if he's getting
comfy like this belongs to me is another dark
twist in parallel for Jon Snow and Daenerys
his story.
So remember how Daenerys eventually started
succumbing to the targaryen madness.
She took the fast Dragon to crazy town became
kind of paranoid the Jon Snow will try to
assert his claim for the iron throne and take
it from her.
Despite the fact that he kept telling her
he did not want it will on House the Dragon
it's the opposite of that situation Daemon
and Rhaenyra's previous spouses both wind
of dying under mysterious circumstances the
same year.
After which Rhaenyra remarries to daemon her
uncle making Daemon's claim to the iron throne
that much stronger keeping him next in line.
So you see more scheming and plotting going
on in the background the whole ideas that
in the present day of the show Rhaenyra is
the only living child of Viserys the first
the former King he's Daemon's brother.
So until Viserys has a son with his second
wife Alicent Hightower this character here
Daemon is technically still next in line for
the iron throne.
But then what happens is when Rhaenyra gets
a little bit older, she is this a cheer this
younger version of her character Viserys the
first decides to name her his official successor
in his will in forces all the lords of Westeros
to back her claim for the iron throne, so
that someday when he eventually dies he's
trying to prevent the line of succession from
jumping over her.
Just because she was a woman.
But then after that happens later in the timeline.
He gets remarried to this character here Alicent
Hightower in they have a son, which completely
complicates things.
So now Rhaenyra is in the clear successor
anymore because the king has a son, so half
lords of Westeros are like will the king had
a son should the next son become the king
in Daemon is no longer next in line for the
iron throne because Rhaenyra had also gotten
married to later Velaryon the sea snake's
son here.
She had a couple sons with this younger person
here effect.
This banquet that they're having in the trailer
seems like their wedding because the banners
above them inside the iron throne room.
It wasn't until Rhaenyra's first husband in
Daemon second wife died mysteriously in the
same year under strange circumstances that
Daemon was able to get remarried to Rhaenyra
putting him back first in line for the iron
throne, so that should give you a pretty good
idea for what kind of a person Daemon is remember
the middle seasons of game of thrones after
to Daenerys started to amass her Army and
her Dragon started to get bigger and she started
talking more and more about reclaiming her
throne what belong to her what was rightfully
hers taking her kingdom of Westeros back daemon
targaryen is a lot like that.
Like he desperately wants his own kingdom.
He has way more dragons the Daenerys and is
much more of a schemer and plotter than she
ever was.
He is a much bigger temper and he's way more
hotheaded like the later version of Daenerys
that burned Samuel Tarly's father and brother
and fed them to her dragons.
This a lot of other footage of Daemon throughout
the trailer here.
Even though you don't clearly see his face
during the tournament scenes in the trailer
you can ask you see him fighting this other
night in his full black and red targaryen
Dragon armor notice the scales pattern built
into the design because is meant to look like
he's wearing Dragon scale armor as you would
expect the targaryen to do his helm has Dragon
wings on it and he's wielding the valyrian
sword dark sister given to him by the former
King his grandfather Jaeherys the first you
could also make a comparison to radar targaryen
because Rhaegar targaryen war armor that look
just like this during Roberts rebellion.
It was also a great warrior.
Just like Daemon targaryen was the Rhaegar
did not lust for power like Daemon did any
didn't have Daemon's temper the tournament
scenes in the trailer might actually be from
two different tournaments there was a really
important tournament in Daemon's history right
after he got dark sister earlier in the timeline
when he was much younger the other tournament
scene where their having the joust here you
see all the house banners like you see the
how stark banner you see two women sit down
to watch the joust this later tournament is
a little bit more important because it's kind
of the start of the actual dance the dragons
conflict where they get the names of the two
factions the Blacks and the greens.
Because what happened was is that Rhaenyra
and Alicent Hightower the two different sides
in the factions both came to the tournament
wearing different gallons so Alicent Hightower
came wearing a green gown Rhaenyra targaryen
came wearing a black out.
Even though it seems that she's wearing a
jacket over her down.
She probably wearing a black down underneath
this in that's why they call the two different
sides in the war the Blacks and the greens
because the color of gallons they wore at
this tournament, but like I said, even though
they are thought of as the two main characters
on the show really Daemon is kind of like
a third faction in and of himself the name
of Daemon's Dragon was Caraxes he rode
him in many many battles based on a lot of the
behind the scenes that we've been seeing them
filming for the show, it sounds a were going
to see at least some of those this also what
seems like a funeral pyre for Balerion the Black Dread
Like you see all these Dragon candles here
in this giant Dragon skull.
Like it's a dead Dragon wouldn't up happening
to Balerion the Black dread is that Viserys
the first when he was going to become king
was supposed to ride Balerion the Black dread.
Like each new king typically wrote Balerion
because the Dragon lived over 200 years old.
So many different targaryens kings.
Besides Aegon the conqueror rode him. Right
before Viserys the first took the throne Balerion
wound up dying of old age.
Like he was already extremely old when Viserys
was becoming king.
So, just seems like he's in mourning for Balerion
like he's lamenting the death of Balerion
with this is happening here.
Like this is some sort of monument to him.
The other really cool thing about Matt Smith
daemon targaryen character is the legends
about what happened to him at the end of the
dance the dragons.
So obviously the Civil War ended in certain.
Someone did ultimately wind up winning the
game of thrones.
During this era, but during his final battle
in the war his dragons body was found
Caraxes wound up dying.
But nobody ever found his body.
So they're all these theories amongst the
people of Westeros that he secretly survived
and lived out the rest of his life with his
lover nettles whose also important character
in the series.
Daemon had a number of different lovers through
his history in the series.
But nettles wound up kind of being.
Like his version of Ygritte.
Like the woman that he truly loved amongst
all of his lovers and wives.
I wouldn't say that it's too similar to what
Jon Snow did at the end of the main series.
I'm expecting the House the Dragon showed
to have some fun with that theory, however
many seasons it runs the true fate of Daemon
targaryen's will is for the first couple of
seasons do not be surprised if he's wearing
some plot armor, so to speak.
But there's so many of the things that happened
to him.
So many other big twists and turns that all
talk about in future bonus videos.
You could say the same for pretty much any
of the main characters will try to do bonus
videos for all the big characters in the next
couple of months as we get ready for the new
show to start will probably get a couple more
teasers for House the Dragon before the end
of the year in the first really big trailer
usually comes in January their kind of back
on the same schedule as the main show used
to be in the early seasons.
If you have any big questions about the characters
are what's going on of this period in history.
Just in general or bonus videos that you want
me to do just let me know in the comments below
Everyone click here for my full House the
Dragon trailer video breakdown and Easter
eggs and click here to learn all about kit
harington's black knight character in the
new a turtles trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see in the next one!